euh David a l'idé a lancé un appel pour
se rapprocher de Jad et Joy c'est ça il
leur a tendu une une main une une m qui
est assez on va rappeler que j et Joy
c'est qui j et Joy c'est ce sont ces
deux dem ENF c'est deux ces sœur ce sont
les filles que Johnny et laticia ont
adopté et qui ont aujourd'hui 15 ans et
19 ans ouais c'est tout ça pousse oui et
donc en fait dans son livre Meur album
il il parle parle d'elle et et notamment
de la relation que Johnny avait avec
elle et il leur dit il leur dit que
voilà que ce que qu'il que le que sa
porte à lui lui sera leur sera toujours
ouverte et que il a envie de renouer le
contact avec elle c'est normal c'est
normal c'est tout bah c'est tout tu venu
pour
ça je peux
dévopperu vendu pas vendu la maison de
il est4 on est V dans la s'il te plaît
s'il te plaît calmeto laiss laisse faire
l'immobiliera reste dans
T va dans le train fantôme nous fais pas
chier euh les Chéries immobilier ou là
là
Anouna il est 20h47 on est en direct la
question que tous les Français se posent
je vais vous montrer la maison et je
vous donnerai la réponse après la maison
de Johnny vendue pas vendu c'est la
question que tout le monde se pose B moi
je vais vous donner
moi je vais vous donner la réponse dà on
va revoir un petit peu la maison il
s'agit d'une villa privée d'environ 1000
m car j avec pelouse est très jolie
c'est ça alors là vous la
voyez au top du top alors VO alors s'il
vous plaît s'il vous plît un grand
séjour de 11 m car de plein pied c'est
dire qu'il y a plein de pieds dans
le il y a une terrasse avec jardin et
parquet et cheminé donc voilà donc ça
c'est ça alors voilà c'est donc c'est ça
c'est en espèce de retour c'est la
terrasse sur la ch chambre quand vous
êtes dans la chambre il y a une terrasse
c'est pas mal je crois que c'est la
chambre ça voilà donc la chambre on va
voir on peut voir la chambre s'il vous
fa de jaunis on peut voir la chambre de
Johny voilà ça c'est la chambre de
Johnny et là-bas là-bas derrière donc
là-bas derrière une salle de bain et
après il y a un énorme dressing o où
Johnny metettit toutes ses tenues et
cetera magnifique
euh il y a d'autres chambres ça c'est
des chambres al il y a des chambres
d'enf
h voilà ça c'est ch alors là déjà c'est
un peu ça c'est une chambre un peu voilà
ça c'est c'est une chambre de garçons ça
euh il y a une chambre enfant également
tout en haut tout en haut regardez il y
a une salle de cinéma de jeu avec un
puis il y a un vélo qui où le mec veut
se barrer
pour non mais c'est vrai il y a alors il
y a une salle de sportarka il y a
peut-être 50 machines ah oui en fait
mais il y a plein de machin ouais non
mais c'est ça c'est-à-dire que les
Johnny il avait un truc il kiffait
acheter toujours les nouvelles machines
de sport donc il les entassé dans sa
salle de sport c'était son kiff à Johnny
et c'est vrai qu'il y avait toutes les
dernières machines euh voilà pour pour
la muscu il y a une donc la piscine la
piscine la pistache moustache ma
grand-mère a des moustaches euh voilà
voilà la pistache moustache alors ça
c'est rien
çaen ça pour ceux qui se demandent ça
c'est rien ça on va le refaire c'est
déjà budgeté vous inquiétez pas on va le
refaire c'est rien du tout c'est des
petites infiltrations qu'on a eu l'été
dernier mais ça ça sera he vous
inquiétez pas on va tout
refaire vous inquiétez pas pour ça il y
a le tennis alors le tennis alors là là
vous voyez le tennis alors alors vous
voyez le tennis alors il est pas
complètement voyz il des petites ça
c'est rien du tout aussi on comptait le
refaire le filet vous inquiétez
pas le filet on
diraita voilà on c'est pas ouf voilà
mais voilà alors la maison est-elle
vendue sachez que la maison de ouf elle
était au départ à 26 millions
d'euros puis elle est passée à 15 puis
elle est passé à 12 c'est une Tirolien
puis elle est passée à 10 millions et
demi d'euros aujourd'hui elle a annoncé
à 100 million et demi d'Uros mais on
sait qu'elle part aux alentours de 7 8 à
8 elle part sûr ah oui
ils ont demandé 26 ahoui quand même oui
bah oui ils ont demandé 26 moi aussi moi
aussi moi aussi moi aussi je pourrais pu
en demander 26 de n'importe quoi elle en
demandé 26 parce qu'elle elle a des dtes
bien s voà donc bon il y a la réalité du
marché myiam Palomba votre version des
faits et je vous donnerai la mienne
est-ce que la maison de de Johny est
vendue non elle n'est pas vendue c'est
une fake news que vous avez dite l'autre
par comme ça on dirait la mer de
reen tu rev
de de dira la mer de pour la mer de l'
c'est une grosse fa c'est à moi tu
parles comme ça non non la maison n'est
toujours pas n'est toujours pas vendue
et et elle est pour l'instant il y a il
y a très peu de visite en plus donc elle
est pas prête à être vendue pour
l'instant alors moi mes infos qui qui en
général sont plutôt bonnes donc tu es en
train de me dire que mes infos sont
plutôt mauvaises non mais sachez moi je
vais vous dire la vérité ils étaient sur
un coup finalement c'est pas fait ah
elle n'est plus vendue elle n'est pas
vendue la maison n'est pas vendue non
non la maison n'est pas vendue il y
avait quelqu'un quelun qui s'est
intéressé je te le dis à moi qui s'est
intéressé à il y a une offre non non il
s'est intéressé pas cher il s
intéressé intéressé mon gars mon gars s
intéressé pas
cher aujourd'hui c'est mort il y a plus
de clients la maison pour l'instant elle
reste comme ça
inhabitée voilà et pour
l'instant il y a pas il y a pas de
visite il y a rien c'est même même le
celui qui s'occupe de de de faire de
faire les ventes dit qu'il y a zéro
visite que d'ailleurs ils vont peut-être
l'enlever des des sites pour que un peu
la mettre au repos par elle elle jouit
en fait d' d'une mauvaise notoriété et
du coup ça oblige enfin ça ça empêche la
vente effective de cette maison donc
c'est très compliqué ça va être dur à
vendre c'est très compliqué av pourquoi
la ville l'achète pas pour faire un musé
de Johnny TR ils ont pas le droit parce
que la coprpriété moudra jamais su déjà
renseigné
ouaier il voulait faire un parc
d'attraction Johnny
land te casse pas alors je vous dis la
vérité j'ai eu tous les mecs tous les
mecs de Paris m'ont appelé pour je vous
dis la vérité tous les mecs de Paris qui
sont un peu dans l'immobilier m'ont
appelé pour me dire pourquoi on
nachèterait pas la maison de Johnny
ensemble pour faire un musé Joh j'ai les
gars vous êtes complètement con il dans
dans un truc avec plein de les mec
vontoir toute la journé des
garsett de Johnny la journé
dans e drôle et là e il va fermer sa
guele Johny Vegas là he parce que jusque
là ok est-ce que je peux poser une
question à l'agent immobilier est-ce que
quand on visite cette maison elle y a
tous les meubles ou elle est vide a tous
les meubles et vous trouvez pas que ça
c'est impressionnant c'estàd que tout
d'un coup c'est trop connoté Johnny et
peut-être que ça impressionne les
achore justement lour elle a été un peu
quand même nettoyée il y a pas il y a
moins de chososees moins de de de
d'effets personnels dans cette mais
c'est un chanteur c'est génial me la
piscine toute la soirée c'est un
chanteur
abandonné qui a vécu tu vas fermer ta
gueule c'est drôle tu vas la fermer
maintenant chez toi tu vois tout le
temps Le
Cam
de on veut
[Applaudissements]
bord c'est incroable le de
jacqu c'est vrai ouais mais oui ce sera
mon Rê j'ai une question pour vous
a ouais en tant qu'agent immobilier
toujours parce que si votre pote n'a pas
réussi à l'acheter non non mais bah un
pote mais le pote vous voulez dire j'ai
un pote
excusez-moi client pas vendu ok oui mais
est est-ce parce que il voulait un prix
trop bas parce que d'après nos infos
myiam et moi Cyril sur toutes les
agences où elle est elle est à 10
millions et demi et pour le moment elle
ne veut pas baisser c'est la seule
manière de purger la dette pas descendu
trop bas est ma question mais vous avez
pas répondu le pote c'est vous ou
pas vois bien
mais est- que cétait trop bas le prix
qu'il a voulu investir dans la maison je
sais pas je connais pas
[Rires]
ceantag
mobilier je l'ai déjà dit je te l'ai dit
à 4 bares c'est ça non mais voilà 4 bûes
tuas tu as le notaire ça va te coûter
frère 7 % sur qure barres bah tu sais
combi ça va te coûter ça va te coûter
370000 à peu
près 1 m²r tu as 1000 m Carr je
t'explique 1000 m²r pour faire un truc
bien non avec le jardin et tout c'est
2500 € par M Carr oui mais oui donc
frérot déjà tu vois le calcul et encore
je suis gentil là si tu veux faire des
travaux voilà en vérité si un mec qui
veut un mec qui achète ça il va vouir
faire des travaux de ouf il va faire
4000 € du m carré ça veut dire ça il va
en avoir pour quatre barres de travaux
donc la maison tout tout compris va lui
coûter 9 9 10 c'est l'achète 4 donc je
t'explique é pendu comme un moment elle
aura pas le
choix gag oui mais cyil si je puis me
permettre oui à 4 c'était le prix que
l'État pensait avoir en cas
d'adjudication ils ont renoncé s'il la
metta aux enchèes il p qu'ils auraient 4
ou 4 et demi et donc mais oui mais ils
ne l'ont pas fait parce que ça ne le
raortait pas assez latia a dit avec 4 et
demi je peux pas vous rembourser mais
oui mais quand vous
dit ser unrai problème entre
l're à mon avis parce que moi moi je ce
je casse vraiment les prix oui mais elle
va elle peut partir à 6 mais même 6 6 et
demi mais le gars qui l'achète à 6 6 et
demi il a l'air insolide derrière parce
que elle va lu elle va lui coûter 12 moi
ce que ce que j'en sais c'est que ltia
pour l'instant il est hors de question
pour elle de baisser les
prix l'état de l'immobilier en ce moment
je t'explique ça
va comme le disait g il y a un but à
cette vente donc
det de rembourser la det tu vas pas dire
à l'acheteur je rembourser la
det pas vendre que de vendre à mais elle
acheté 4li donc elle va pas laendre
acheté 4 ben je t'exlique si moi je
laend ou en ce moment en ce moment je
t'explique tu vas pas faire de plusvu en
ce moment mobili plus mal je t'explique
et puis là c'est à Marne la coquette
frère vas-y à Marne la coquet tu vas
deux fois la troisème fois tu dis j'ai
un
lambbago il a bien vendu ça va 2 minutes
conna il conna million con c'est bon bon
allez